macht ja Kommunen schlagen schon lange
Alarm sie wissen nicht mehr wie sie die
vielen Flüchtlinge unterbringen sollen
es mangelt an vielen vor allem an Geld
heute großer flüchtlingsgipfel in der
Hauptstadt auch dort wird ums Geld
gestrichen ja und Bund und Länder die
schieben sich die Verantwortung hin und
her jetzt gehen wir mitten rein das ist
nämlich das Thema von Tobias Bauschke
wie ist die Position der FDP und wie
kann den Kommunen geholfen werden
ja Migration Flucht die großen Themen
der letzten Jahre und es werden Themen
der nächsten Jahre bleiben und die Frage
glaube ich die wir uns alle stellen
müssen Geld alleine wird die Situation
nicht mehr
lösen können wir werden
tiefer in die Materie einsteigen müssen
wir müssen uns systematisch darüber
unterhalten und wir müssen glaube ich
auch für uns als Gesellschaft definieren
was wir von Integration erwarten was wir
welche Ansprüche wir an Migration haben
denn es ist eine absolute soziale Frage
und
was wir geben können glaube ich das
stellt sozusagen gar keine in Frage die
Frage ist sozusagen eher die
Erwartungshaltung und da würde ich zum
Beispiel und das bereiten wir gerade
auch mit dem Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz z.B vor es ganz klar
an das Thema Arbeit binden wir haben den
Arbeitskräftemangel wir haben den
Fachkräftemangel und wir müssen endlich
lernen dass wir das Thema Migration
extrem mit dem Thema Arbeit verbinden
müssen und bei Fluchtursachen bei
fluchtgründen schneller werden müssen
digitaler und besser werden und das
Thema ist Risiko und ich freue mich auf
die Diskussion ja das Thema ist riesige
sie haben zwei Punkte angesprochen das
bedeutet also ganz konkret denen die in
Not sind denen die vor Krieg fliehen
helfen
selbstverständlich alle anderen sollen
arbeiten wollen wie wollen Sie das
konkret umsetzt naja indem wir sozusagen
ja jetzt gerade an dem fachkräft der
Einwanderungsgesetz arbeiten indem wir
sozusagen ein punkte-modell einführen wo
wir sagen wer gewisse Qualifikation hat
kommt leichter zu uns und kriegt eine
Arbeitserlaubnis ich bin auch großer Fan
davon dass wir sozusagen darüber
sprechen dass im Grunde eigentlich seit
Tag eins wenn man nach Deutschland kommt
dann auch eine Arbeitserlaubnis
ausgestellt wird weil es hilft auch der
Integration das hilft sozusagen auch dem
Spracherwerb des wissen war alles und
ähm wir müssen für die Menschen die
sozusagen keine Bleibeperspektive in
diesem Land haben
so hat es klingt natürlich auch
schneller dann in Richtung Abschiebung
gehen und das ist momentan ein Ritt auf
der Rasierklinge die Bundesländer haben
fast keine Kapazitäten mehr zu
Unterbringung wir finden keine wirklich
gute Lösungen sowohl zwischen Bund und
Länder und wir haben natürlich schon
auch so wirkt es manchmal für mich wenn
wir jetzt zum Beispiel auch mal nach
Bremen gucken und sowas in der Situation
wo ich mir immer eine ganz sicher bin ob
sozusagen auch die jeweilige
Landesregierung da auch versucht einfach
Druck auf den Bund noch mal zu erhöhen
um auch noch mal mehr kosten sozusagen
über den Bund abzuwickeln und das ist
eine ganz ganz ungute Debatte weil sie
im Grunde auf dem Rücken von Menschen
geführt wird und das finde ich unfair
Debatte die jetzt auch in Berlin geführt
wird Frau Hermenau wo die Fronten so
scheint sich auch ziemlich verhärtet
sind das was herausstellt gerade gesagt
hat das haben wir ich hoffe sie nehmen
mir das nicht rum aber natürlich schon
oft gehört das sind Sätze die kennen wir
in dieser debat also wenn ich das mal
etwas zu viel Sand anmerken kann weil
das unsere Anfänger war heute die AFD
hat sehr lange gefordert dass man nach
Punktesystem die Einwanderung
neugliedert wenn ich das richtig
erinnere vom Anfang ja vielleicht ist
schon länger in der Programmatik da gab
sie auch
geschrieben haben kanadisches Modell ja
aber sie haben es ja nicht nach vorne
getragen der Punkt an dem ich festhalten
möchte ist ich glaube nicht dass man
harter abschieben kann die Praxis zeigt
dass das nicht funktioniert man muss
also bei der Einreise ansetzen bei der
Verabschiedung kann man nichts mehr
machen aus meiner Sicht da das immer
wieder zu völlig Erfolg meisten Fällen
geführt diejenigen die abgeschoben
werden sollen verstecken sich tagsüber
kommen nachts raus überfallen vielleicht
noch jemand weil sie kein Geld haben
sonst also ist alles furchtbar
Katastrophe Abschiebung ist eigentlich
das schlechtere der Mittel das bessere
Mittel ist die Einreisekontrolle wir
hatten unsere Honig Prozent der
Deutschen fordernde Obergrenze das auch
vielleicht aber wir hatten ja vor allen
Dingen in corona-zeiten haben wir ja
gemerkt wie schnell auf einmal Grenzen
zu sein können das geht ja
das war es auch sehr überraschend
nachdem man behauptet worden war
jahrelang da seit 2015 das ginge nicht
der entscheidende Punkt ist die
deutschen trauen sich nicht sich selber
zuzugeben dass sie eigentlich
Arbeitskräfte brauchen die auch in die
Sozialkassen einzahlen zumindest ihn
nicht auf der Tasche liegen und das ist
eben nicht so weit her ist mit der
eigenen ökonomischen Stärke wie sie
gerne immer alle glauben oder ihn
glauben gemacht wird dieser Mangel an
Einsicht über die eigenen ökonomischen
Möglichkeiten führt dazu dass wir immer
mehr in so eine Situation reinkleiden in
der wir die Dinge nicht mehr beherrschen
die landete und Bürgermeister am Ende
der Nahrungskette bei den öffentlichen
Finanzen schlagen jetzt zu Recht Alarm
weil die nicht mehr wissen wie sie es
machen sollen wenn der sagt er hat kein
Geld dass er dafür ausgeben kann wenn
die Bürgermeister sagen sie haben kein
Geld dass sie dafür ausgeben können und
wenn die Landräte sagen sie haben kein
Geld dass sie dafür ausgeben können
würde ich das mal zur Kenntnis nehmen
und sagen okay können wir uns nicht
leisten dass die alle kommen geht halt
nicht dann ist das so aber nein das
traut sich dann wieder kein Haus zu
sprechen
dass keiner auszusprechen wir haben
jetzt ziemlich Klartext gehört von der
Frau Hermenau wird dieses Thema zu
vorsichtig angegangen ich bin jetzt ja
noch nicht so ganz lange in der CDU ich
bin tatsächlich auch kein
einreiseexperte kein fluchtexperte ich
bin auch kein
Migrationspolitik Experte ich kann nur
aus der Klima Geschichte noch mal sagen
dass wir da ziemlich am Anfang sind von
dem was an Flüchtlingsströmen auf uns in
die Ländern im Norden noch zu kommen
wird und wir glaube ich gerade eher eine
Nummer zu klein denken also auch mehr
klimaflüchtling definitiv also
Zahlen im Kopf haben dabei können Sie
davon reißen
in Asien ich hatte vorher gesagt sollen
die Hinsicht zu Tode dann
Jahrestemperaturen über 40 45 Grad mit
einer hohen Luftfeuchtigkeit von 60
Prozent heißt es Aufenthalt im Freien
ist nach drei Stunden tödlich so der
wohnt 3 Milliarden Menschen in diesen um
den Globus drumherum die werden da nicht
dort bleiben und warten bis irgendwie
Silvester 2023 oder 25 und was kommt
sondern die werden sich immer in
Bewegung setzen dass wenn kriegerische
Bewegung sein werden wahrscheinlich auch
mehr Tourismus oder in Terrorismus haben
oder ähnlichen denn dort ist ein ein
riesen Problem wo es um not um Überleben
geht und die werden sie Bewegung setzen
da werden wir uns ganz anders mit
beschäftigen müssen dann werden
vielleicht und da spreche es nicht für
die CDU sondern als jemand der sich als
Bürger Gedanken macht während
möglicherweise über einen zweiten oder
dritten Arbeitsmarkt reden der mit ganz
anderen Preisniveaus unterwegs ist weil
ja jemand erst mal nach Deutschland
kommt und die Sprache lernen muss und
damit noch nicht beispielsweise
komplizierte Aufgaben in der
Produktionsanlage übernehmen kann auf
der anderen Seite brauchen wir
Pflegekräfte die fehlen auch überall in
allen Ecken und Enden
wir hören ja da ist ja auch jetzt schon
die Situationen erfahren heute
Klimaflüchtlinge glauben sie da kommt
noch viel mehr auf uns das ist auch
wieder so ein Märchen es gibt keine
Klimaflüchtlinge denn sonst würden wir
auch die Inder die haben es nämlich auch
ziemlich heiß ja die würden wir alle vor
der Tür haben warum kommen die nicht
weil sie ein ganz anderes
Gesellschaftssystem haben diejenigen die
fliehen fliehen aus vielen
verständlichen Gründen es geht in
wirtschaftlich schlecht oder sie sind
unterdrückt wir haben in Afrika eine
Reihe von
Staaten die alles andere in der
Demokratie in der Demokratie sind das
sind die Gründe von von
schlecht geführten Staaten und deswegen
muss man da ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
aus klimagrunden kommt dann bis jetzt
keiner aber wichtig ist natürlich dass
man sowohl bei der Einreise da versucht
man ja jetzt offenbar etwas zu tun an
den Außengrenzen aber es geht ja wohl
noch weiter dass man sagt eigentlich
müssten die ja Nordafrika sich
einschreiben und wir müssen sie dort
überprüfen müssen sie erstmal in Italien
sind dann kannst du auch nicht
zurückschieben aber wichtig ist ja so
einfache Dinge wie das die Grünen es
seit fünf Jahren verhindert haben das
nordafrikanische Staaten als sichere
Staaten anerkannt worden sind ich meine
wir fahren da nach Tunesien in den
Urlaub nach Marokko und aber Georgien
Moldawien wir haben es bis heute nicht
geschafft wir können wir dürfen nicht
einmal das Gericht würde es sofort
zurückpfeifen wenn jemand nach Marokko
wieder abgeschoben wird oder nach
Tunesien und das ist doch etwas wo man
jetzt sagen muss das der andere
Initiative des Bundesgesetzgebers des
deutschen Parlament gewesen also schmort
jetzt im Bundesrat und die Grünen nehmen
die CDU sozusagen in Geiselhaft und
sagen nee das wollen wir nicht ja da
muss man sich auch mal ein bisschen
ehrlich man ob das dann viel hilft weiß
ich nicht ich finde den Vorschlag von
Friedrich Merz dass man die die die
Entwicklungshilfe zumindestens mit ins
kalkülze das kann doch nicht sein dass
der Sozialhaushalt in Deutschland
von Leuten geplündert wird die wirklich
kein Anrecht haben hier zu sein und wir
aber gleichzeitig in diese Länder
Milliarden Abdrücken an
Entwicklungshilfe das muss man doch
koordinieren dann sagt man lieber okay
wir machen ein Programm das die Leute
dort Beschäftigung kriegen aber wenn das
dann nicht zu zur zu Kontrolle der
Auswanderung führt und Rücknahme dann
gibt's auch kein Geld ich finde das sehr
wir sehen hier auch in dieser Runde das
ist eine hochkompliziertes Thema das uns
sicherlich auch noch einige Zeit
verhaftet also die Fachkräfte in der
Pflege z.B ähm das ist nicht unbedingt
identisch mit den Regionen auf die sie
abgezielt haben sondern also es wird
sehr schwierig sein junge Männer aus
arabischen afrikanischen Länder davon zu
überzeugen ältere deutsche Frauen zu
pflegen und ich glaube es wird auch
schwierig sein ältere deutsche Frauen
davon zu überzeugen dass sie von diesen
Männern gepflegt werden
wohin das führt wenn man solche
nebelkatzen will dann überlegt sich das
jemand vielleicht und denkt darüber nach
was das bedeutet also man hat natürlich
auch Fachkräfte die muss man hier
ausbilden da muss man hier Ausbildung
anbieten mit Vietnamesen zum Beispiel
wird das zum Teil gemacht im
Pflegebereich das weiß ich zufällig dann
heißt es aber auch dass man sich auf
diese Ausbildung einlassen muss nicht
jeder ist dafür geeignet es gilt wie für
die Deutschen für alle anderen auch ja
nicht jeder Mensch ist für alles
geeignet
da hat man große Problem
Sendung wirklich behandeln können
herzlichen Dank an meine Gäste für diese
hochinteressante Sendung und natürlich
auch ganz herzlichen Dank an sie fürs
zusehen bis ganz bald wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie